[Música]
hablamos de deportes en directo américa
de france 24 ya estaba conmigo listo en
el estudio luis méndez yuri che luis
comenzamos entonces esta segunda crónica
deportiva de la mañana en europa porque
aquí todavía hay reacciones lo que fue
el partido entre rafael nadal y novak
djokovic es que tiene que serlo raúl fue
un partido sumamente emocionante un
partido que se extendió por más de 4
horas y fue el compromiso número 59 en
esta ocasión entre ambos tenistas en
esta oportunidad el partido se
desarrolló como parte de los cuartos de
final y dejó ahora al
campeón de 13 veces del roland garros en
este caso rafael nadal a un triunfo para
igualar la serie particular entre ambos
raquetas pero para ampliar más detalles
de esta situación vamos a conversar con
nuestra compañera natalia ruiz tira
giraldo natalia buena tarde para usted
allá en europa y quisiera consultarle
sobre la emoción que dejó este partido y
si será la última vez que vimos a rafael
nadal como tenista en parís
muy buenas tardes feroces dos hoy desde
londres y pues efectivamente eso que
vivimos anoche en ese estadio philippe
chatrier en algo long agost creo que es
de las pocas veces el año pasado tuvimos
la oportunidad de estar allí también
cuando se disputó esa semifinal entre
ambos jugadores pero el ambiente anoche
era muy distinto tal vez para quienes lo
vieron por televisión no pudieron captar
ese instante sus primeros momentos de
juego en el que ese enorme estadio que
estaba a reventar pues estaba en
completo silencio verdad casi como un
silencio de iglesia y en realidad para
el primer punto se demoraron 10 minutos
antes de finalmente definir y creo que
si no me es todo no recuerdo mal ese
punto fue para rafael nadal y otro de
las cosas y es que cuando rafael nadal
saltó a la cancha está está este estadio
philippe chatrier finalmente bueno
reventó en jolgorio de aplausos mientras
que cuando novak djokovic entró hubo
menos aplausos y uno
uno que otro abucheo había esa digamos
esa esa era el ambiente anoche con la
gente que quería que rafael nadal
avanzará teniendo en cuenta también que
parecía que partía como menos favorito
que no va a que él djokovic por lo que
había venido mostrando por el partido
anterior ante o realia si me que había
sido bastante laborioso y no valió kuyt
que mientras tanto pues no había cedido
ningún set a lo largo de este roland
garros y será el último o no del de los
enfrentamientos entre los dos ahora
habrá que ver cómo van las cosas como
esta ambos para para wimbledon pero
seguramente ahora rafael nadal lo que
dijo es que va a concentrarse
precisamente en este partido que hoy se
entrenaría un poco mañana ya será mucho
más a fondo para estar listo para esa
semifinal que será una semifinal
bastante dura antes haya zverez más
teniendo en cuenta el partido que vimos
jugarle a carlos alcaraz
natalia la saludo muy buena tarde allá
de en londres aprovechó que está
entonces en necesidad para hablar sobre
el ambiente que hay en torno a la
finalísima ese partido que enfrentan los
campeones de la copa américa y la
eurocopa
así es pues ya hemos visto muchísimos
hinchas sobre todo de la albiceleste que
vienen además en familias esa hinchada
que siempre es tan fiel al equipo
argentino ya hemos visto muchísimos aquí
en las calles de londres en los hoteles
llegando también en los trenes pues
mucha emoción sobre este este partido
entre el campeón de europa el campeón de
la de la conmebol el campeón
sudamericano y bueno e italia que salta
saltará a la cancha del estadio de
wembley nada más y nada menos allí donde
hace un año ganó la eurocopa y que
espera entre después de 35 años poderle
volver a ganar a argentina y les hago
una pregunta rápidamente ese última vez
que italia venció a argentina fue un
partido 3-1 quien habrá marcado ese
único gol de la argentina en 1987
y si me corté yo no sé si lo sabe porque
es experto en deportes pero no recuerdo
ese partido del 87 pero sí recuerdo
claro lo que fue el partido de 1990 esa
semifinal para darle el triunfo a
argentina y luego enfrentará en la final
a alemania en aquel entonces partido que
terminó 1 a 1 y definieron por penales
natalia de aquella ocasión
así es así es un partido muy doloroso y
bueno para el dato entonces pues ahí en
ese gol del 87 lo marcó nada más y nada
menos que diego maradona así que como
verán bastante historia y en todo caso
para los dos equipos las cosas son un
poquito diferentes italia quiere a toda
costa ganar este este trofeo el día de
hoy porque vienen siendo un poco como un
trofeo de consolación en vista de que
ellos no clasificaron o para captar a
final de año mientras que para argentina
va a ser en realidad una buena prueba
una buena manera de medirse a uno de los
grandes europeos justamente de cara a
este mundial que va a disputarse a final
de año pero se espera así que sea un
gran partido roberto mancini lo dijo
ayer en su conferencia de prensa que de
todas maneras un partido entre argentina
e italia pues es realmente un clásico y
que son dos grandes equipos los que van
a enfrentarse esta noche aquí en londres
así así que usted va a tener el
privilegio de disfrutar natalia
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información esta vez desde londres
nos vemos mañana con más para pues
hablar lo que fueron estos los
pormenores del partido louis también
muchísimas gracias por toda la
información deportiva ustedes continúan
con nosotros
noticias24
[Música]